[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
marielle de sarnez femme politique
française figure du centre militante
européenne combattantes de la justice et
de la liberté n'est plus de la
révolution ukrainienne à la transition
démocratique en tunisie de la
reconnaissance de l'esclavagé comme
crime contre l'humanité par l'union
européenne au développement du programme
erasmus de ses engagements en syrie en
irak à son analyse visionnaire des
crises migratoires de ces combats aussi
comme élu de paris pour le logement des
classes moyennes à la couverture du
périphérique pour désenclaver la
capitale elle nous laisse d'abord une
oeuvre politique dans une époque où
beaucoup s'interrogent sur le rôle et la
place des élus le parcours est l'action
de marielle de sarnez apporte des
réponses
elle était la politique cet important
l'action publique au plus haut degré
d'exigence que marielle de sarnez a vécu
son engagement de toujours au centre de
valéry giscard d'estaing à emmanuel
macron ferraillant aux côtés de françois
bayrou qui avait trouvé en elle un autre
lui-même parce qu'elle aussi avait
trouvé en lui un autre elle-même
ensemble ils ont permis à ce courant
politique de vivre de survivre aux
tempêtes de revivre toujours au service
du pays l'affirmation de convictions
profondes
tout en reconnaissant la légitimité de
conviction contraire même si on les
combat suscite le respect sur tous les
bancs et de toutes parts les hommages
ont été innombrables et unanime comme
rarement
soyez tous remerciés il arrive dans nos
vies de rencontrer des personnes qui
nous rendent meilleure pour ceux qui
m'entourent ici c'est ce que fut
marielle de sarnez dans une sororité
politique nous manqueras temps désormais
à ses enfants dont elle était si fier à
ses petits enfants dont elle parlait si
tendrement à tous ses amis comme à ceux
qui furent ses adversaires je veux dire
qu'elle fait partie de ces êtres dont il
émane et tant de lumière qu'elle
continuera tels les étoiles quand elles
s'éteignent d'éclairer encore longtemps
nos chemins
[Applaudissements]